білоруська армія не налаштована на цю
війну тепер людей можна затримувати за
неправильний колір шкарпеток за жовту
блакитну стрічку у волоссі
нещодавно одну 21-річну дівчину посадили
на 6 з половиною років за коментар в
Instagram зупиніть війну
- це люди і понад 90% білорусів проти
цієї єдності Росії та Білорусі
до мене приєднується Світлана
тихановська лідерка опозиції в Білорусі
незалежній білоруські ЗМІ пишуть що в
Білорусі триває таємна мобілізація
Лукашенко зараз активно долучається до
війни Путіна
Насправді те що зараз відбувається в
Білорусі щодо режиму це величезна
імітація діяльності
Лукашенко хоче показати що він усе
контролює що він важливий тому він
працює тут чи там відмінує кордон чи що
завгодно просто щоб імітувати діяльність
нас є
і ми також чули у ЗМІ про цю таємну
мобілізацію але результатів її немає
Отже Лукашенко намагається погрожувати
Україні погрожувати іншим нашим сусідам
щоб він залишався в центрі уваги ніби
він важливий
тому я б не казала що білоруська армія
приєднається до Російської цій війні
тому що в білоруських солдатів немає
морального духу воювати проти українців
і білоруська армія не налаштована на цю
війну
вони не розуміють Чому вони повинні
воювати проти наших братів українців за
чиїсь амбіції а не захищати країну
звичайно ми розуміємо що маємо справу з
непередбачуваними диктаторами
і Лукашенко може зробити дещо йому не
каже Кремль Але я вірю в білоруський
Народ я вірю в білоруських воїнів що
вони не зрадять нашу Батьківщину
[музика]
Міністр закордонних справ Росії Сергій
Лавров заявив що фокус Москви
розширюється зі Сходу України на міста
на півдні та Можливо на іншій території
Наскільки Ви стурбовані тим що Білорусь
може бути в цьому списку щоб Путін може
анексувати Білорусь у якийсь момент у
найближчому майбутньому
звичайно ці плітки щодо можливого
референдуму в Білорусі також широко
обговорюється але ми повинні розуміти що
країна - це не рішення однієї людини
країна - це люди і понад 90% білорусів
проти цієї єдності Росії та Білорусі
ми особливо після 2020 року зрозуміли
наскільки важлива наша ідентичність що
ми абсолютно різні народи з Росією
[музика]
і Немає потреби об'єднувати нас Отже
такі плітки можуть дестабілізувати
Білорусь
Я впевнена що в Кремлі розуміють що
білоруси будуть боротися за свою
незалежність за свій суверенітет так
само як і в Україні
вони думали що люди зустрінуть російські
війська з квітами але людей ніхто не
запи і вони піднялися люди воюють проти
цих військ так буде й в Білорусі
тепер Давайте поговоримо про роль
Німеччини у всьому цьому чи вважаєте ви
що Путін все ще має занадто багато
важелів впливу на Німеччину особливо
коли йдеться про залежність від
викопного палива зокрема нафти та газу
ми побачили майже психодраму чи повинна
Німеччина скоротити імпорт російського
газу
торгівля газові та нафтові відносини між
країнами розвивалися багато-багато років
і зараз я думаю що влада хоче думати про
національні інтереси
але для такої потужної країни важливіше
бути відданим цінностям демократичним
цінностям
і Я майже впевнена що німецький уряд
намагається шукати шляхи виходу з цієї
ситуації через залежність від
російського газу
і знаєте є дійсно вважаю що зараз Настав
час для рішучості
для сильних рішень і я сподіваюся що
народ Німеччини зрозуміє рішення вашого
уряду
[музика]
А якщо говорити про роль Німеччини щодо
її спротиву агресії Росії то де ще
Німеччина повинна бути активною
яким був би ваш поселення німецьким
депутатам тут у Берліні
Ки
Ми звичайно говоримо про Білорусь перш
за все
у Німеччина насправді дуже послідовно
проводила політику щодо Білорусі щодо
визнання режиму щодо підтримки
громадянського суспільства
[музика]
ви прекрасно розумієте За що ми боремося
і я думаю що варто залишатися
послідовними не дозволяти режиму
обдурити уряди знаєте укладати будь-які
угоди за спиною білоруського народу
Хоча я бачу сильні позиції щодо Білорусі
але завжди пояснює що можна було б
зробити набагато більше
набагато більше Можна було б зробити для
студентів самі правозахисників науковців
тощо Німеччина потужна країна і багато
сторін дивляться на рішення Німеччини
тепер Настав час бути двигуном постійних
рішень
Лукашенко дав інтерв’ю заявивши що
Білорусь є авторитарною країною але в
ній немає політичних в'язнів Яка ваша
відповідь на це
хи
звичайно Він так говорить тому що він
хоче бути меншим ворогом за цих обставин
але кількість політв'язнів у Білорусі
зростає з кожним днем
зараз це приблизно 1500 осіб людей
щоденно затримують з політичних мотивів
за участю мирних акціях ще у 2020 році
і не ведіться Не давайте себе обдурити
диктатором Він завжди говорить те в чому
хоче переконати перш за все себе
а насправді людей можна посадити на роки
у в'язницю лише за антивоєнну акцію
це як нещодавно одну 21-річну дівчину
посадили на 6 з половиною років за
коментар в Instagram зупиніть війну чи
щось на зразок того
тепер людей можна затримувати за
неправильний колір шкарпеток за жовту
блакитну стрічку у волоссі
це політичні рішення ви знаєте Можна
було б виносити обвинувачення Щодо
економічних справ але всі ці справи
політично вмотивовані тому що люди
наважуються сказати Ні війні і цьому
режиму
вашого чоловіка Сергія тихановського у
грудні Минулого року засудили до 18
років позбавлення волі як він зараз
і він два роки був ув'язнений і звичайно
Він велика людина важливо розуміти що
умови для політв'язнів у білоруських
тюрмах Набагато набагато гірші ніж для
звичайних злочинців
наші люди мають там спеціальні позначки
тобто вони не можуть донести іншим
ув'язненим що їх принижують фізично і
морально
їх там катують але наші люди які
пожертвували своєю свободою вони вірять
у нас
Вони вірять у сильній потужній країні
які будуть віддані цінностям за які
людей ув'язнено
ми боремося за них
і дуже важливо не кидати цих людей це
найгірше відчуття коли відчуваєш себе
покинутим забути
зараз дуже легко не помітити Білорусь у
цій війні в Україні
я прекрасно розумію що ми повністю
підтримуємо Україну в цій війні Але ми
не повинні забувати про політв'язнів
репресії продовжуються у в'язницях у
нашій країні
і важливо надавати людям відчуття
впевненості
що ми з вами що ми Вас підтримуємо ми
знаємо що ви зробили
Світлану тихановська Дуже дякую дякую